the opening scene features a courageous
journalist who is seen recounting all
the past incidents of the war and
documenting it all in her diary she
prefers to remain anonymous as a result
of which she is addressed as anonyma as
she recounts the scene flashes back to
the year 1945 depicting the last days of
the second world war in Europe it turns
out the Soviet Union Unleashed three
fronts from 45 m east of Berlin in order
to capture the city on that day anona
kisses good by to her husband who is a
high-ranking German soldier in the Nazi
party following this departure she goes
to hang out with her upper class friends
as usual during this she talks about the
ongoing condition of the world and also
believes that their country will win the
war the group remains oblivious to the
invasion of Soviet troops until a huge
explosion disrupts their party as they
run for their lives we see the
devastation of Nazi Germany where
buildings are destroyed everywhere amid
this bombing run a anima along with
other civilians comes across an
underground bunker that houses an
assortment of women children and several
elderly people anonima recognizes a few
people in the shelter most of them are
scared of leaving behind their Noble
occupations or missing loved ones who
participated in the war she also
Witnesses a grim sight of a woman
suffocating due to her exposure to the
chemical weapons used by the Soviets as
she sits and grabs a drink she p on
their present struggle and de decides to
write everything she sees for her
husband later during a brief ceasefire
the Soviet troops march on the streets
searching for surviving Germans they
also order the German soldiers to come
out and surrender themselves however the
Nazis refused to accept an easy defeat
so they choose to put up one final fight
they open fire from the top floors and
balconies of the buildings and managed
to take down several enemy soldiers
despite this the overwhelming number of
Soviets eventually overpowers them in
the aftermath Major Andre ribin receives
a phone call from his Superior ordering
him and his Battalion to Halt their
further progress to Reich Stog in the
meantime one of the Soviet Soldiers
locates the hidden civilians in the
bunker anonima who has traveled to more
than 12 countries and knows several
languages tries to distract the soldiers
by talking to him in Russian however her
efforts prove futile as several young
women are summoned out of their hiding
an anima walks out and Witnesses the
whole streets surrounded by the Soviet
Army who are all celebrating their
Victory the women are then interrogated
and teased by the Soviets making them
feel uncomfortable as a result anonima
runs back to the underground only to see
a young Celestia girl being abused after
waiting for the right moment she quickly
hands the girl keys to her old Penthouse
and urges her to flee the scene
following this anonyma stumbles upon
another Soldier forcing a German woman
to an abandoned room for his
gratification in an attempt to help her
she pursues them to the room but when
she tries to trick him the woman runs
away trapping her alone with the soldier
aware of the impending assault she feels
terrified but manages to remain calm in
a dark action she lures the soldier into
a dark room and locks him behind a cage
before fleeing she then goes to Major
Andre and requests to stop the abuse
however he disregards her concern
claiming that the soldiers are clean and
healthy to do anything they want
disheartened she returns back to the
bunker only to be pulled by a soldier
Into Darkness and foron in the next
scene a kind German Widow allows anona
to stay in an apartment complex with
other surviving civilians later while
conversing one of the Abused Women
mentions that the Soviet troops are
planning to eliminate all the Germans
soon their conversation is suddenly
interrupted when the Soviets break into
the apartment in order to abduct the
women as a result all the civilians
begin to flee except for anona who
thinks that running away is futile
following this the Soviet soldiers spot
her and well all right these incidents
become a daily ordeal forcing the women
to submit themselves for the solders
pleasure over time anona conditions
herself to endure the solders demands
degrading herself even more despite such
hardships she tries to uplift the
spirits of the women assuring them that
they will survive however at one point
anona is forced to go through a
particularly rough ordeal unable to
tolerate it any longer she accompanied
by another woman named Barbie goes to
see Major Andre and complains about the
brutal assault in response the major
dismisses them recounting how the German
soldiers did much worse things to
Russians in the past battles despite
facing rejection anonima doesn't give up
and goes to Lieutenant anatol to ask him
for help the latter agrees on the
condition that she has to serve him this
afternoon she accepts the offer thinking
that she she can at least be saved from
the lowly solders Relentless assaults
later that day anatol invites anona and
some German civilians to party with his
fellow soldiers in an apartment as they
all enjoy themselves anatol and anona
engage in a fun conversation after the
party everyone retires to bed while
anona has to fulfill the Lieutenant's
desire the next day she returns to her
apartment and sees Major Andre who has
come to meet her however she ignores him
because he didn't care about any of her
previous complaints in order to make it
up to her he instructs one of the
soldiers to fetch water and soap for a
bath a Russian medic Masha is furious by
what major Andrea is doing as a result
she personally delivers the bathing soap
to anona and vents her anger by throwing
the soap on her feet also declaring that
Berlin is theirs later on the major
makes everyone leave and talks to anona
in private expecting him to seek the
same gratification as others she enters
a room and undresses without a word word
when he sees the bruises all over her
body he finally feels bad for how the
women are being treated and walks away
several days pass by but the Soviet
soldiers are still abusing the German
women the major feels sorry for the
situation but lacks the courage to
confront his team in the meantime anona
continues writing her experiences in her
diary in her note she describes anatol
as a gypsy who comes and goes as he
pleases a few days later Major Andre and
a few of his soldiers come to the Widow
woman's apartment carrying some
delicious food they then sit together
with the German civilians and enjoy
their time conversing not long after
another group of Soviet soldiers led by
Lieutenant andropov break into the
apartment building and start barging
into each room hearing the commotion
Major Andre and the others walk out to
inquire what's going on to which a
soldier claims that he saw an armed
German Soldier stealing their food he
suspects that the thief lives on the top
floor of the building but anona denies
this it actually turns out that a young
German Soldier has been staying in the
penthouse with the same celestian girl
from earlier in order to extract the
truth the soldier starts beating up an
elderly man which enrages major Andre
the major then beats up the soldier
nearly killing him in Rage as the crowd
disperses Major Andre goes to the
bedroom with anona and Embraces her
tightly indicating that he has started
liking her later when the major leaves
anonima goes to the pent to warn the
celestian girl but to her surprise she
finds the young German Soldier who chose
to stay hidden instead of going to
Siberia with his comrades unable to
figure out how to react she simply walks
away deciding to keep the encounter a
secret in the following days Major Andre
frequently visits the civilians
apartment and spends some good time
together also offering them protection
over time he grows closer and closer to
an Ana sharing personal details such as
his bank account passport the names of
all his twinks and wow and even the
names of his relatives but unbeknownst
to him anona continues to have secret
intercourse with anatol this makes her
scared that the major might find out
about this one day and well kill her one
fine day anonima is returning to her
apartment after fetching some water
during this she bumps into her old
friend elk who has been out of town the
two are Overjoyed to see each other
again anonima brings her to the
apartment and introduces her to the rest
of the residents following this the
women spend an entire day sharing their
experiences with the Russians in
particular they gossip about their
sexual encounters with the Soviet
soldiers and even make fun of them more
like Russian to the Finish Line a few
days later the artillery general of
Germany comes to announce that Adolf
Hitler has committed the unthinkable
which means Germany has lost the war he
orders all the remaining soldiers to
surrender because any resistance will be
in vain the news brings brings Joy to
the Soviet soldiers who then starts
celebrating in the streets beginning
with their national anthem on the other
hand the friendly group of Russians
returns to the civilian apartment with
gifts and food Major Andre plays a
soothing tune on the piano creating a
peaceful atmosphere after a while he
goes to see anona in her bedroom and
they have some private conversation it
is at this moment that he confesses his
feelings for her and asks her to
accompany him to Russia she is clearly
hesitant but she opts not to answer him
for now meanwhile a drunk Soldier goes
up to the penthouse and proceeds to
force himself on the celestian girl
seeing this the young German Soldier
reveals himself and opens fire on the
drunk man however he misses the shot and
as a result a physical brawl ensues
between the two soon after the Soviet
Soldier throws the boy from the top
floor which results in his death this
commotion alerts everyone prompting them
to gather in the stairway the celestian
girl swears allegiance to Hitler due to
which she is immediately executed the
soldiers then demand to know the owner
of the penthouse and anona admits that
it is hers hearing this Lieutenant
androv tells the major to punish her but
the latter refuses the lieutenant
threatens to report the incident to hire
officials but the mayor seems to be
ready to Bear all the consequences for
anona in the aftermath the soldiers
continue their rry while Major Andre
appears clearly fed up after some time
he had back to anonima room where she is
currently serving ANL surprisingly the
major does nothing more than ordering
ANL to leave after this he compels all
residents to gather in the living room
to celebrate Hitler's Demise by drinking
singing and dancing the party soon
escalates and everyone eventually begins
to enjoy themselves after the party
Major Andre talks to anonima in private
once again urging her to come to Russia
with him as his life partner however she
is forced to decline saying that she
still has a husband who will be coming
home soon hearing her refusal he
prepares to leave but she halts him and
passionately kisses him following this
the two end up spending a night together
this makes it clear that anonima also
has genuine feelings for Andre the next
day she visits her neighbor ilsa Hulk
only to be confronted by a heartbreaking
sight ilsa's retired military husband
has committed the unthinkable likely due
to their defeat in the war anona then
tries to soul ilsa but her efforts prove
futile following this anona grabs a
bicycle and goes in search of Major
Andre to seek help but she cannot find
him anywhere after a while she returns
back to her apartment and is shocked to
find Lieutenant andropov along with her
husband gird waiting for her the
lieutenant hands her a note from Major
Andre informing her that he is about to
be transferred to an undisclosed
location due to the previous incident
after the lieutenant departs gird
confronts wants anonyma visibly upset
towards her she tries to explain that
she does not live alone in the apartment
she also hands him her diary and tells
him to read about all the suffering that
she has endured since the Soviets
invaded Berlin she hopes that gird will
understand the situation she was in at
the time but the latter is so
disappointed that he refers to her as a
disgusting woman afterwards anonima
rushes to the military Camp to meet
Major Andre one last time even though
she is saddened by his departure she
expresses gratitude for protecting her
and for treating her well before parting
ways they hold each other's hands and
wish for each other's wellbeing anonima
then returns home only to find her
husband wreaking havoc in the apartment
but despite the chaos she refrains from
uttering a word of intervention a couple
of days later gird leaves the place
without notifying her anonyma narrates
that she does not know where he went or
whether he will ever return to her in
the final scene it is revealed that when
her d diary was initially published in
Germany in the year 1959 it faced
indignant rejection labeled as a
disgrace to German women shocked by the
contempt from her contemporaries the
author refused to allow any further
editions to be published until her death
as a result even after her passing her
name remained a closely guarded secret
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching k